[Music]
check
yes
got a cool explainer video today okay we
got a special guest they're all cool
okay oh thank you thank you thank you
explainer videos
i got one of my people oh my gosh yeah
yeah let me get them right off the top i
got brian cox brian welcome to star talk
this is not your first rodeo with us but
i'm just saying welcome back
it's a pleasure to be back with you um i
should i should say for all the people
watching you should have seen the behind
the scenes because you all think it goes
really smoothly and it's a well-oiled
machine
i think it's taking us half an hour to
plug the microphone in yes it is
it's almost like 10 monkeys typing out
something for fox news
[Laughter]
inside joke people
inside
so uh professor brian cox he's professor
of particle physics at the university of
manchester
and he's also
at the royal society uh what is your
title there as a professor for public
engagement in science professor for
public engagement in science we meet one
of you at every single institution in
the world no no no no no chuck every
single street corner yes
would that be great though if we had one
at every so for i'm just saying europe
is is leading this or
england especially the uk uh there are
multiple professorships for the public
understanding of things
and uh so
they understand
the value the public understanding of
science public understanding of math
there's another one a public
understanding of of risk am i right on
that brian yeah that's good full list
there so david spiegelhaltzer is a and
as you say um as you well as your great
friend carl sagan said we live in
societies that are based
on science and technology whether we
accept it or like it or not and
therefore to have a functioning
democracy people need to know a little
bit at least about the process how we
acquire reliable knowledge and that's
been so visible in the pandemic where
that wasn't even known about two and a
half years ago and i think it is
difficult for people to understand how
to get reliable knowledge
and uh trusted sources
so brian i
by my read of the of the landscape you
are more popular
as a
physicist in
the uk than carl sagan ever was
as an astronomer in america and because
you were a literal
rock star you know oh rockstar and
physics no you were actually a rock star
just remind me of this you had a top 10
a song on the charts
we had a number one
[Laughter]
so who was we what was what cool when
was i i've been in two bands actually
one was a rock band called dare which
was um
actually i'm in los angeles at the
moment and we recorded our first album
in
1987 i think it was in los angeles so
remarkably the first time i'd ever been
out of the country but then i had
another band called dream and we had a
song called things can only get better
which is a gross misunderstanding of the
second law of thermodynamics and i'm
given what i've learned later i'm very
ashamed about the title and it should
have had a series of caveats that
entropy always excuse me
it was hopeful
in america it's okay to be hopeful about
things yeah but that song was in number
one and ultimately uh tony blair used it
in his election campaign in 1997 so it
became a very famous
song in the uk
so so we so you were more famous as a
rock star before you became famous as a
physicist
yeah well i was a keyboard player though
and we you know keyboard players it's
kind of a cliche isn't it because if
obviously a physicist would be a
keyboard player yes with all the lights
and
they're not going to be
you're not going to be a lead guitarist
and then become a physicist that's
well ah you say that but brian may oh
brian man
you're right has a phd in astrophysics
yeah
there you go
yeah so it's this british invasion you
guys like what's up with you all plus
you still have the beatles haircut i
mean come on
i think i'm getting a bit old for that i
think
i think i should no you hey listen
hey brian you rock that as long as you
can my friends
you got hair like that you just rock it
as long as you can
well you've written books you've made
all kinds of uh tv series for the uh bbc
uh on on the universe on the solar
system on on one was on life too is that
right or was it yeah tackling all the
frontiers of important interesting
frontiers and there's some people who
still come up to me and say
they want to see another
nerd fight with you that i had a few
years back over twitter
it was like nerdfight nerdfight
i i i passively started this because i
didn't know you were paying attention i
said because i think i just come back
from comic con and so i addressed my
tweet to comic-coners and i said you
know if lightsabers
are
beams of light
then since beams of light can pass
through each other
just see what flashlights do
then
then you couldn't have a saber fight
with the blades bouncing off each other
and and and and i was perfectly happy
putting that out there but no
brian cox has to ruin my perfect tweet
what was your rebuttal
what's with some particle physics facts
okay brian no he's not pasca it's it's
nature facts it's physical okay
no i i
worked on um what we call gamma gamma
scattering which is photons particles of
light scattering off each other so at
very high energies
then there is a reasonable probability
that two two particles of light two
photons will bounce off each other and
gamma rays are the high energy that turn
david banner into the hulk so that's
some serious high energy there yeah
there is but it's even higher energy
than that but so it was kind of a
pedantic um
point i've got a track record by the way
um um eric heidel well you have been on
our show the infinite cage with eric
idle um he he asked me once eric idle of
multiplier monty and eric idle
uh when they did live shows in london um
he asked me to do a video criticizing
the galaxy song so those of you that
don't know he was a very famous in the
meaning of life a song a monty fighting
song called the galaxy song and it says
how fast the earth's revolving and it's
in orbit around the sun and i said well
it's not quite in a circular orbit it's
in an elliptical orbit and so there are
things that are just as a joke there are
errors and so he asked me to call
stephen hawking
and see if stephen hawking will be in a
comedy sketch with us and stephen agreed
and the sketch was that i would be
criticizing the galaxy song in cambridge
by the river saying well of course
that's inaccurate because these
elliptical orbits and blah blah blah and
the sun is not the source of all our
power because there's uh there there is
uranium and it's other stars it wasn't
the sun and all this sort of stuff and
stephen comes flying along
the river
in his wheelchair and knocks me to the
ground
and says i think you're being pedantic
and then he starts singing the galaxy
song
so
yes so you're in good company accusing
me of being pedantic because stephen
hawking also
famously
accused me of being potential
i'm going to say that
that was the most intricate way of
dropping a name i've ever experienced
well
i called stephen hawking i'm just saying
i got my speed dial right i'm just
letting you know it's like that's like
i'm just like you know it's just like
well no actually the story is this and
then it ends up with me just going and
then barack and michelle just said okay
let's go
you aren't true you are correct
but not to mention eric idol
exactly yeah yeah yeah so so
so then you know as i tell people that
however geeky you are however
card carrying
one is on the geek spectrum there's
always someone geekier than you are
it's just simple so i put out a geeky
tweet and someone flies in across the
pond and says and out geeks me and i i
think at the end i just i just
graciously conceded it's like yep yep
yep it's not someone neil it's not just
anybody stephen hawking's friend
[Laughter]
steven hawking's buddy
well played sir
so just to be clear just to put this to
rest the a lightsaber if however it's
designed even if it didn't bounce off
each other in a sword fight style you
can still pack enough energy to cut
people in half and harm them with such a
weapon so that was never the question
here the question was whether you can
actually have a sword fight with them as
they bounce off each other and if they
contained high enough energy gamma rays
they would do this is the point yeah
it's a very much in principle
discussion
it was the future they would they would
design it that way i got no problems
with that
um
so so i noticed on the calendar that
you're not in the usa for no reason you
actually have a stage
performance
with the co-host of your radio show
podcast uh which is titled infinite
monkey cage i've been twice a guest or
three times a guest on that show it's a
fun program it has a similar kind of
structure to us because i have chuck as
a as a comedic co-host you have robin
ins who is your comedic co-host he's a
professional comedian keeping you
grounded and honest just as from from
the episodes i've seen
and so now you're taking this on the
road this is amazing and uh the title as
i've read is called horizons which is
very deep in the universe oh my gosh so
so tell me about horizons what are you
working on now with horizons the the
show is um it's designed around
these huge screens that in the uk
where people have heard of me we play we
have like 15
15 000 seat
arenas so so we put together this huge
um show with vast led screens and we're
bringing them as much led as we can to
the us but it's about um it's a
cosmology show it's
the horizons works on multiple levels i
mean as you as you said i'm doing
research into black holes at the moment
so there's a great deal of interest in
event horizons of black holes and what
they're telling us about the nature of
space and time so the idea that space
and time are not fundamental that they
emerge from as einstein said something
deeply hidden right a deeper structure
of the universe so there's that sort of
central idea
there's also some
classical music in it there's a
because it's also a celebration of us of
humanity and what we what we could
become so where we came from um it's uh
as we've discussed i think before um
there's a there's a possibility at least
that there are very few civilizations in
a typical galaxy you can even make the
argument that maybe one on average in a
typical galaxy
so there's a that there are there are
ideas there about our value
and how we should see ourselves what it
means to be human there's one there's a
central question i always i kind of like
to wind philosophers up
and i always say there's only one
interesting question in philosophy
which is what does it mean to live a
finite fragile life in an infinite
eternal universe
and that's what i start the show with
and i try is that before after you give
out the weed
that's true you get free
free additional help
to process these existential questions
yeah you need you need some extra
chemicals
in addition to that you're going to need
therapy when the show is over
the reason i mean essentially the reason
we've got music in it is because um i
think the questions raised by cosmology
as you yourself saying
that the questions
are
um
fundamentally human questions that
people have asked for many hundreds of
years
such as that you know what what does it
mean to live a finite life um that that
you're forced to confront that when you
know that there are
in the observable universe there are two
trillion galaxies depending on which
survey you look at there are 400 billion
suns in the milky way galaxy i think
that your immediate reaction is to feel
small and insignificant right but my my
argument is
a little bit hurried just just a bit
like i have a bit more urgency now just
hearing you say that
you're gonna die this you know this
century right i'm dead in a few days and
basically you're talking about billions
of
yeah yeah i think it's they're
challenging subjects um but
the great artists the great musicians
for centuries have faced similar
questions they're questions that are
raised just by existing
and so that so the show tries to um
put those bizarre discoveries about
black holes and the wider universe into
some kind of context to make some sense
of it so there's physics there's
philosophy and you're you're on the
doorstep of religion uh with some of
those questions and
uh
this sounds this sounds like a a night
out
a fun time to be had by by all and how
many cities this again in this british
invasion how many cities are you going
it's 26 cities we start on the east
coast crazy dude yeah that you are a
rock star
i'm telling you i talked didn't i tell
them
no it's yet to be proved you see because
because anyone can go and talk in 26
cities as you said if you're a rock star
if anyone comes true
someone's going to i mean i could stand
on the street corner as you said yeah
and it's like an important distinction
yeah chuck yeah yeah remember we got a
physicist in the house you gotta
distinguish the question and the point
you're making yes you're right you're
right
so and um you're working on a book now
uh is it also on this same subject it's
it's on black holes and i got really
profoundly interested it goes back
actually to stephen again which we
should not to name drop now it's a it's
stephen it's steven now yeah stephen
hawking
way back in the in the 70s he calculated
he showed that black holes um radiate
so so although they're things that we
think of as prisons where anything that
goes in can't get out
over a long time they evaporate away so
that was his great contribution
so-called hawking radiation
and that raised a question that he asked
first which is what happens then to the
stuff that falls in over its lifetime
when the black hole has gone
is there any trace of that stuff left in
the radiation in the universe when the
black hole is evaporated and that's a
profound question because where did the
information go i guess exactly because
it is there are lots of information
his calculation initially suggested that
there was and he he stood by that for
many years because his calculation no
one could find a problem with it but is
his calculation specifically said that
black holes destroy information which
which attacks the foundation of physics
everything
it's yeah it's determinism it's the idea
so the eternality of matter itself he
called into question and so i'm going to
ask you two
was he right
no he turns out he wasn't right and he
accepted that in the in the end actually
and in the last couple of years there's
been great a great insight into why
it is that his original calculation was
was wrong and it's extremely subtle
very interesting
what we've discovered which is just
fascinating is that by trying to
understand the simple question that
stephen raised we're being forced to
confront the idea that space and time
are not fundamental that they emerge
from some deeper theory and that's a
it's know what no one expected that when
we started thinking about black holes
phenomenal
because it's that's a for most of the
way we think and most of how science
unfolds it starts with that premise you
have space and time from which all else
issues forth
and you're saying
space and time itself may issue forth
from something deeper that that's what
the the lesson
of black holes is it seems to be okay we
need a whole show on that okay wow
that's some juicy stuff
yeah
all right well brian welcome stateside
for this british invasion and we'll
catch you when you come through new york
because we're back in new york here and
you're in l.a uh and so uh delight to
have you and for all those at what what
website can we can they find you to get
tickets they can find it brian cox live
dot co dot uk
and that that's where you'll you'll find
it all okay dude all right this has been
another explainer video with a very
special guest a friend and colleague
brian cox chuck always good to have you
man it's a pleasure
this has been star talk explainer time
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you